- Right after I proposed to her, she goes,
I wanna take a picture with
my new ring on in the ocean.
- You know, social
media wants that moment.
- That was not the moment
where the ring got lost, thank goodness.
(Classical music)
- I proposed.
- Well, 'cause I was begging for years.
- It was back and forth
for the last three years.
It was cheaper to get married than
to buy another plane
ticket, so here we are.
- And also, he loves me.
- And also, I love her.
- It was on New Year's
Eve when I proposed.
- We were only seven months into dating.
Nobody was pregnant.
- We got to spend our first
week of marriage sleeping
in a small tent and so, that
was kind of our adventure.
- Who lost the ring and how
- Molly
- [Narrator] did that all happen?
- Molly lost the ring.
- Okay, it was stolen.
- It was not stolen.
- I asked my aunt if I could have
my grandmother's wedding
ring to give to Jackie.
She was like, put the
ring in your backpack.
She said to me, right, Jamie,
I'm gonna give you this ring,
but please don't lose it.
- The first ring, I ended up
being allergic to the metal.
- I'd taken the old ring,
and I went and exchanged it
and bought a really nice traditional ring.
- I wasn't allergic to
the metal of that one.
I was allergic to the style of that one.
- I was living with my roommate Erin
and I was watching her dogs
because she was out of town.
Put it next to my bed and in
the morning, it was not there.
And I look at these sweet dogs,
and they weren't so sweet anymore.
- I put it in my gym bag, safe.
Did a really hard work
out, yes, I'm amazing.
Go back to the gym bag and it was gone.
My ring was the showpiece.
It was rose gold, diamond band.
- Stop, it hurts me
- with a big rock.
- to hear you talk about it.
- Got on the train, put my
bag next to me, fell asleep.
And then I heard the
announcer announce my stop.
And I jumped off of the train,
went up the escalators, and
it was when I got to the top
that I realized I didn't have my bag
which had the wedding ring.
- So I don't know who has my wedding ring
but I hope they're enjoying it.
- But it's not her, yeah.
- For and a half days, was going through
all the poop of these dogs,
really feeling the hotness of it
and I could not find this ring.
And then I look in between
my bed and my bedside table
and my ring is wedged in between.
- I had no idea that this even happened.
- I took it off to shower
and it fell down the sink.
- Then you have to call
the whole plumber thing,
and then he was searching
for it, couldn't find it.
You said it fell down
the sink or the shower?
- The sink, the bathroom sink.
- Okay, did you lose that ring?
Did you not lose that ring?
- It's gone.
- Obviously, it's gone,
but did you lose it?
- I don't know where it is.
- Anna.
- I don't know where it went.
- Well, whatever, I mean, she's my wife.
I love her to death, so no matter
if I gotta buy a ring every year.
(classical music)
- Ooh.
- Please tell me my
lost ring isn't in here.
- Yeah, right?
- This one's pretty, it
looks like my actual ring.
- I like, you can stack these, look.
- I think this would be awesome for
working out and stuff 'cause I
always leave my ring at home.
- They make me wanna go rock climbing.
- After I'd lost my ring, I was panicking.
So I causally throw out the,
hey, we should get these Qalo rings.
- This is the most fun I've had all week.